[Musique]
peut-être vu il s'agit de donald trump
sur le perron la maison blanche publié
sur les réseaux sociaux
hier pendant 8 secondes on voit le
président américain respirer de façon
anormale comme s'ils forcé son
inspiration c'est exactement ce qui se
passe infectés par le coc u19 donald
trump présente sur cette vidéo des
signes indéniables d'insuffisance
respiratoire tapis cow boys sur un
réseau social ici twitter et des
centaines de photos de couples
homosexuels apparaissent des résultats à
l'opposé de ce que prône ce groupuscule
d'extrême droite américains
masculinistes et raciste et c'est bien
là le but de la communauté gay détourner
le hashtag prod boys les gars sont fiers
en français et en faire un mot de
ralliement et de fierté homosexuelle
entre jeunes vous êtes l'homme qui avait
quand même coupé au montage
donald trump dans wall street l'argent
ne meurt jamais en 2010 il avait il a
été totalement coupée au montage
mais il avait deux pages de caprice de
demande incroyable déjà présidentielle
des conditions de tournage
invraisemblable mon dieu mon dieu mais
quel scandale
c'est un personnage absolument
incroyable comment diminuer qu'on peut
pas recréer dans le décret à venir un
nouvel orage autour de lui chaque jour
que dieu fait il peut raconter jaune
absolument épouvantable et puis
lendemain il se réinvente
c'est un vrai professionnel de la chose
mais ça fait du bien de fayoter de temps
en temps d'ailleurs merci beaucoup à
pauline pour vos extraordinaires
qualités à la tête de cette matinale le
soleil de nuit quand il appelle avec
louis on peut le dire à l'antenne aussi
ça fait plaisir vous n'êtes pas du tout
failli au charles pas du nom ça vient
naturel et j'adore ces deux petits gars
très jolie maman je crois que j'ai
entendu ici je me souviens qu'il y avait
qui avait une émission vous a parlé de
toi on dit on n'a pas à dicter tout cas
je me souviens pas du tout d'avoir des
saf
je me sens un peu forcé je vais quand
même faire les excuses à ma soeur mais à
ce moment-là série c'est parce que j'en
ai besoin
gvt est mais un peu timidement et mal à
l'aise mans parce que voilà c'est pas
spontanée de poulet trouvera même les
zones ont trop gros pas ses mains cg1
présente a mis un peu de ketchup et un
peu trucs dedans pour faire une sauce
démange et j'essayais de gens nés
d'erlon ça c'est le récurrent
elie limite on envie de vomir c'est mon
corps qui me le dire
non c'était franchement dégueulasse
florent peyre il fait du fait l'appel du
uss laisse moi rire
cyril c'est pas une secte du 110 m haies
parus dans la presse et c'est surtout un
événement qui a été filmé à pau c'est un
essaim d'abeilles qui c'est qui a pris
pour subvention de signalisation un feu
de signalisation voyez donc côté du coup
on voyait plus le bleu le rouge le vert
voilà là tu fais ce qu'ils peuvent a
s'est pas facilité du nectar mais il
avait encore faim dont il est dit sur
une deuxième fleur prélever un petit peu
plus de nectar et il prend aussi un peu
de pollen au passage à ouïr regarde ça
au passage antoine a prélevé du pollen
car si antoine
allah qui ont choqué
et j'ai fait
là
l'accessoire qu'il fallait avoir chez
chanel la nouveauté c'est le sac et 5
partout des mini sac apporté on met quoi
en mai 2 euros et une carte de crédit
mais prévoit des tout-petits saken il a
même des dessins qui se portait un
bracelet vous allez voir là ici je les
ai ralenti up saissac vaste et pourquoi
pour mettre un masque j'imagine oui ou
un masque ou qu'ils ont elles c'est
caroline karine roland la nouvelle
adjointe à la mairie à la culture à la
mairie de paris rachida dati bas pendant
plusieurs minutes l'empêcher de parler
avant d'être recadré madame dati vous
étiez inscrits sur la délibération vous
êtes des inscrits
quand même un peu bizarre d'intervenir
pendant que madame roland répond à
madame dumas
madame dati madame la présidente dati
c'est madame karine roland pire est peut
être encore moins d'habitude jean
plafonne les hausses que rentrer dedans
jde écrase qu'un saute dessus je suis
pas là pour les caresser d'are suède du
cha cha cha l'équipe a dans ce lot n'est
vraiment pas mon truc
la peine deux minutes plus tard qui
revient à charge ont fait l'objet
l'oeuvre deux des monades verra même si
saddam dati mais mais je m'énerve pas du
tout c'est fait
j'essaye de pour gc de finir mes frais
ve
rachida dati enlève son masque pour
protester avant d'être rappelé à l'ordre
le port du masque dans cette assemblée
n'est pas optionnelle dans les tribunes
on installe un public haut en couleurs
1800 réplique en carton des personnages
de la série south park censé encourager
l'équipe de football américain des
broncos de denver coronavirus oblige
cartman ou encore kenny prennent la
place des fans du colorado l'état où se
déroule la série animée est bien très
bien cinq minutes de suspension de
séance
alors on s'est renseigné le débat ouais
le débat portait sur la situation du
théâtre du châtelet à paris
mais on est lui m'a confié dati était
surtout là pour visiter la nouvelle
adjointe à chaque chute sur un simple
bon je pense que tout simplement la
question qu'il faut qu'on se pose est
est-ce qu'on n'est pas tout simplement
trop nombreux ou les plus virulents
fasse un peu de place à c'est un peu le
ménage
merci beaucoup et je savais pas si
j'allais mercredi woody à demain